[Music]
we're continuing YouTube week here on
the Rubin report and my guest today is a
scientist who works in chemistry and
biochemistry as well as taking down
social justice warriors in his spare
time Phil Mason a KA Thunderfoot welcome
to the Reuben report thanks for having
me um so what should I call you here are
we going with Phil should we go with
Thunderfoot should we go with thunder
mr. Foote what do you feel whatever
feels both comfortable with you I'm
happy with it all some all right well I
was just telling you before we started
that I'm looking forward to chatting
with you because when I kind of woke up
to all of this regressive left nonsense
and social justice BS and all that stuff
you were one of the first people that
everybody was tagging on Twitter say
talk to this guy talk to this guy so
what we're overdue I think yeah I reckon
so it's been a long time coming it
certainly has okay so for people that
have no idea who you are what you do
you're you're a scientist by day that's
the the first part here so can you just
tell me a little bit about your history
oh well I went I was working at Cornell
for about ten years and while there I've
been fairly productive during the day
I'm so productive in the end that I
actually had a rather lost spare time so
I started making videos on YouTube
because at the time creationist this was
right in the infancy of YouTube and
creationists basically they had a free
run and they were peddling some of the
most outrageous ever and what
really got me into this is I you know I
had colleagues that were going to
government government accountability
office and I showed one of them one of
these videos about this creationist
spouting the most obvious and I
asked me you know what's wrong with this
and of course they didn't have even
today they suspected it was and
that that's why I started making these
videos sort of explaining why it was
and in the early days I was doing you
just because there was a there was a
need for and this still is yeah and that
the problem is the way back then even
now there is no incentive for real
scientists to take time away to actually
counter a lot of these pseudo science
that's out there so that's how I how I
got into it and then some sometimes
later I rubbed up against the social
justice warriors but I would get into
that yeah we're gonna get into that all
right so but let's let's back up to a
little bit of your science background
what got you in to scientists science
and what kind of work do you actually do
oh so I actually really cover a lot of
bases so by training I'm a chemist but
I've done a lot of work in in physics
and biochemistry so yeah I really don't
fit well into boxes when you're trying
to just categorize me like that sure um
and also quite like the Astronomy so it
really does you cover a lot of bases
there yeah so when you saw these
creationists on YouTube in the in the
infancy of YouTube how long did it take
before you said I have to do something
about this because going from the lab to
going to public that's a quite a jump
you have there
yeah and initially it was relatively
stay anonymous on YouTube yeah I never
really showed my face which is one of
the reasons so regrets my grind spiky is
when people say that I've got white
privilege or something because I almost
never appear on camera by all of the
people who follow me never knew what I
look like till about five years in yeah
um so they were zooming you had white
privilege at the time I I don't know but
um yeah things like that all the driving
actually work to get where I
now which yeah I mean things like that
just crazy
yeah what made you take the jump from
doing most of this not that you were
doing it anonymously but without your
face to the point of saying okay I have
to put my face to this because we've
been talking about this a lot now sort
of the balance between there's a need
for some anonymity online especially if
you lived in a closed society and and I
can understand some people that do it
from Western societies but I also have
my frustrations with some of them what
what sort of made that light go off for
you uh well at one point of course I got
doxxed and after that you know this you
can't put the genie back in and it's
inevitable you know the there's only so
long you can go online before someone
just drops drop something the either
accidentally or intentionally and I
still worry about honor I forget I was
in the millions of views point before
someone actually yet before became
public knowledge who I was which I
thought was done okay but me I'm a big
proponent of the concept is valid no
matter where it comes from and yes is
why I do quite a lot of my stuff off
camera because what it looked like and a
lot of things a point of irrelevant in
fact in sight it almost works against
you you get the clean-cut guy with the
sharp suit and a lots of thing in
science you immediately think salesman
salesman and so there
you go with a lot of times if people are
well mmm
groomed like that there's a distrust in
science awesome so is this why we should
trust scientists that kind of have long
hair and maybe you're half shaven and a
little more just shovel Ike mad
scientist would be a little more
trustworthy to you just my love so for
me yes but this is where you get
scientists and universities especially
there are very sheltered society and he
within the actual science
Department that's the where is that's
the bubble there but of course in
reality in the wide world right you want
to go on the news and be taken seriously
even look a certain way right looks
matter I and its bizarrely enough
that was a took me a long time to learn
that that was that was the case and yeah
so you can get people who are ready I
spent a lot of time doing science and
research you would have thought that
it's bizarre that you'd be so naive to
think that you can get away with that
sort of thing with without a certain
look online right so you're saying that
well I don't know if you're quite saying
this but Bill Nye the Science Guy he's
playing the part of the Science Guy for
a sort of palatable digestion purpose
yeah um and I've got no problem with
that whatsoever yeah you know if it I'm
very pragmatic like that in fact so is
he's the he's an engineer but they care
about results rather gets the message
across a wins a win
I went in a tube don't get too picky
about the details right right right so
backing up to the daxing for a second
because I do want to talk about that for
a little bit so that was actually I
didn't realize that was the first time
that you were sort of outed publicly is
that is that correct yeah yeah so um so
you had been completely anonymous before
that yeah yeah so and oh good yeah it
was a Muslim guy of course
and he wrote yeah he was the first guy
he wrote and there's this email log that
cannot email Skype log that came out
afterwards where you know he was
actively going after my dachshund you
know if we care we find out where he
works that'd be the end of him I use
really aggressive stuff considering um I
mean it's true that places like YouTube
and just online in general is a
bloodbath a free speech it's
for the league or the timid but
ultimately it's a flat arena the you can
give us is if you want to disprove
something that's wrong online you can do
it and if you make a convincing argument
people will generally believe it
and so this I mean scoping for someone's
job trying to end their career that's
really nasty stuff yeah especially when
it was absolutely nothing to do with
what I was doing online I mean if I was
you know probably using you know
Cornell's name or what everybody's - to
promote myself then the are fair dues
but I wasn't I was some almost entirely
faceless voice making arguments online
so so in effect you were making
arguments that this guy didn't like he
basically couldn't or refused to counter
the arguments in a in a logical way and
then instead said alright I'm going to
go after his welfare and and at some
level you're your personal saying he is
an illiterate skip he he claimed that he
wrote while he did I know he wrote to
the University here Oats to all the
local Muslim groups and it's like at
that point a you know go sending them my
videos with my name attached and it's
like come on that's does this is a
[Music]
that's pretty cheap stuff in a way he
was probably proving your point about
Islam right um very much though
yeah in fact later on he P went through
a few later spasms but here this
wonderful picture of how he saw Islam
where there are these concentric rings
going to the Middle where there's a
little clear the little black box of
Mecca or whatever and you notice you get
progressively further out it goes from
you know extremists in the middle which
is obviously meant to be pure Islam to
moderate on the outside it's just of
time for upon something but I mean the
thing was that was his view of Islam is
that you had to get to the center mm-hmm
you know
moderates they were you know not really
taking their faith seriously right which
is really the reverse of even you as an
atheist it's the reverse of the way you
would want a religion to be if you
accepted that some people are going to
be religious one way or another by the
average atheist I don't think has a
problem with the nominal believer of any
religion really I know some some do but
well I mean usually anything goes as
long as she don't make claims like my
religion gives me the right to kill
people is there as long as your religion
falls within what's illegal in society
no one cares I mean there are there are
some sort of gray areas about you know
if you're a cult you know how much
pressure can you put on people to coerce
them you technically that's within the
law but these pretty distasteful stuff
do you find it exhausting as a scientist
and an atheist to have to spend any time
talking about religion I've had many
guests on my show who are well-known
atheists and thinkers and and really
bright people who don't believe and yet
have to spend a lot of time talking
about the behavior of believers because
it's impacting their lives I for one I I
find it kind of exhausting I wish we
didn't have to discuss it but
unfortunately we do I think I've had the
conversation so many times now that it
doesn't faze me too much what I find
more the problem is distinguishing pose
from create Adam extremists or one sort
or another you know can you really tell
the people are just pretending to be
religious fanatics from religious
fanatics cuz any other same problem with
the social justice thing is that a can
you tell when they're faking it or idea
do they really believe that so I was
watching a video earlier about what is
it virginity is just a social construct
and really really absolutely and it's
not just one one or two days alike
whole bunch of feminists who say it's
just a social construct and what they
actually mean by that is it's a bit of
behavior of people or something and at
that point is well yeah so the I in
other words when they say social
constructs you've got this idea that
it's sort of imposed on people and
that's what they actually mean at all
it's just a name for behavior well we
ever worked out already it's called you
know behavior or an action or something
you know so virgins orange night sex
that's that that's what it means you
know yeah I'm pretty sure it's a takes a
physical action for a virgin to no
longer be a virgin
yeah Marshall I would you know that was
my fault sorry I don't know how we got
there but I see your point so it's a
well level would you say a theist are
you are you that you want to eradicate
religion altogether I mean I get what
you say about you don't mind as long as
they live within civil society but
obviously you do you do some videos on
this and about atheism do you see a way
for the secular world in a modern 2016
Society to work with religion at this
point so um for the board brush picture
I'm very little about this basically you
can do what you want as long as it
doesn't scare the horses so if people
want to I mean people do all sorts of
weird stuff with their time they do
self-destructive things they like
drinking smoking driving fast cars
yeah people choose what they want to do
with their lives we're very keen on
keeping that there the problem comes is
when it's informing people's actions to
the level of you know I will discuss an
earlier whatever driving trucks through
crowds or shooting crowds or blind
people up or convincing others to do the
same this is for me whether it's a line
for media the other one that I care a
lot about and most people don't
influence the D education
that much but when religion tries to
force itself into the educational system
that for me is a big no-no I mean
teaching kids is hard enough work as it
is without actually to the poisoning
their minds weird stuff that is known to
be wrong because you know in some cases
that's irreversible you have the kids
that that's that's what they've learned
for their entire youth which get about
20-ish your brain's ability to to
relearn stuff vanishes yeah what I say
by isn't your brain 80% formed by your
your to or something I mean your the
elasticity over time I I think I'm
probably watching I probably butchered
that terribly but the elasticity of it
brain does stop yeah I mean your ability
to learn language it is for instance you
know when you're very young it's very
easy once you get into the teens it gets
progressively harder and for most people
trying to learn a language after the age
of about thirty s almost impossible yeah
you lose your right you lose that
flexibility in your brain over time and
it really just you know there's a reason
why I'd occasionally stops around
eighteen is because you know it gets
progressively harder to to so get people
to learn stuff yeah so hearing
everything you've said about religion
that the examples you used about you
know driving a truck in Paris and to
people or shooting people you know like
you get there's a zillion shootings but
we could take Brussels or Paris again or
Orlando or whatever it is but those are
examples of Islamic extremism would you
say all religions are sort of equally as
nonsensical and and it just so happens
that Islam is acting out more now or is
that not I mean some Horus for this
marvelous point the extremism really
isn't the problem
and you know you get the G NIST
extremists there's the ones who like
brush the bugs out of the lady too you
know for fear of stepping on anything
you know who's a filter they're their
water to avoid drinking bugs right
either more extremist they are the less
harmful now the problem is is when
the your religion is actually convincing
you to kill people now Christianity's
been through that you know it's not sort
of unique to Islam but Islam is
currently the religion the you have a
long way is convincing people to kill
each other and yeah that that's a
problem and that that's you know one of
my big beefs if you like with the spread
of Islam is yeah I mean you're right not
all religions are equally bad in this
measure right they all may be equally
made up but that doesn't mean that
they're all equally acted on the same
and that all the urges not equally um
comparable in their ability to get
people to break the law you know peace
of ease of killing people that sort of
thing let's shift away from religion for
just a second and focus on the social
justice stuff which really frames pretty
much everything else about that we're
going to talk about for this hour
when did you realize the problem of
social justice was it when you were
became a youtuber or dad you seen it
first in your in your private life uh so
I can tell I first rub shoulders with it
in 2011 which is a ways back now and it
was within the atheist movement which
would the time was enjoying it with
Golden Age year dawkins Dennett Harrison
and Hitchens and there was a real feel
of momentum to the movement and there
was the this one woman Rebecca Watson
who had never ever heard of elevator
gate now ever heard of that I don't
think so and that's what I first sort of
came up against this sort of feminism in
the atheist movement and so what it was
is one woman had hung out to about four
o'clock in a bar
so she was a regular speaker on the
atheist movement a long time of beef
about people hitting on it which is you
know what happens
if you're gonna hang out on a bottle for
in the morning and this is yeah there is
an expected social venue where this sort
of thing is going to happen and four
o'clock in a bar is that that's the
place anyway right it's always hitting
on you at 4:00 a.m. in a bar you have a
bigger problem now yes yeah all the way
the bottom of the pile anyway so she was
going back to a room and some guy offers
Yogi's goes up in the elevator with her
and says what do you like to come back
to her room for coffee which is
obviously a euphemism for whatever and
she says no and the next day she writes
this blog about how this this shows what
a problem the Atheist movement has with
sexism and at the time it's like you've
gotta be you oh poor o'clock in
a bar at a conference which are usually
love meeting you know mixing places like
that um but at the time I said nothing
because yeah I think it goes even back
to the Bible is you know a house divided
against itself cannot stand
and you know if you're in a fight a
civil war you're gonna suffer more
casualties than anyone else you know
u.s. Civil War is still the war that has
killed more Americans than any other and
so a large part I followed the Reagan
ethic which is you know you don't speak
ill of your own party so to speak yeah
that's not looking to operate anymore by
the way I know it's glorious isn't it
person anyway and so the noise just got
louder and louder and I I actually
thought talked some other these people
who were feminists and they were telling
me how I had privilege and this really
was rub me the wrong way at a time
because it's like you've got to be
me because I started working
burger-flipping in McDonald's you know
the idea that you know oh well you know
I am privileged well what about the
precedent you know does does he a black
privilege because he's now the president
anyway yeah so that was really rubbing
me the wrong way and eventually she had
a punch over Dawkins where he basically
said that her problems were trivial
which they were right if the biggest
thing that you've got to worry about in
the Atheist community is getting hit on
after being the power of till 4:00 in
the morning
you've not got much yeah you've got a
pretty good life and you know he
basically compared her stripes to women
in in Islamic countries which led to be
real is a hell of a contrast anyway so
that's basically what caused the rift in
the atheist movement and yet much later
on I just took the gloves off and it's
like well if we're going to do this
let's make it quick
and that's where I got stuck into the
feminists in the atheist community and
then it turned out you know actually
this is a pervasive problem
it destroyed Occupy Wall Street it
really did it sort of took what wall
what I had a real vibe going to it a
real momentum going to it and it
destroyed it in an astonishingly oh it's
like I forget whether were six months or
a year it went from something that had
potential to something that was a punch
line yeah and not only did it do it
there but we're I think we're seeing
that right this very second with what
it's doing to black lives matter an
organization that in my estimation had
good intentions to start and now we're
seeing it be led by its worst parts and
the example I keep using is that you
know there's this several examples but
one is that they were up in Toronto
during Gay Pride and they stopped the
gay pride parade because they wanted the
gays there to sign a document with their
demands so they said well we're more
oppressed than you I don't even know
that in Canada they're having a problem
with police brutality but this idealism
what's that yeah
don't tell them there's a black
president yeah right you can't not right
right so so it does corrupt everything
right I mean have you seen a movement
that it hasn't corrupted no
and you're right aids now it's a little
tautology in some way use the you know
once you make being oppressed a virtue
then it basically becomes a competition
to be you who can say the most oppressed
and when you can you don't actually have
to be black to identify as being black
and I'm sure you saw this this black
woman who was actually a a lily white
girl who had just so darkened herself up
a bit and she became the black president
of but I forget what it was him I think
she was working for the n-double-a-cp
um yeah yeah it's mind-blowing right
like you know when you if you remove
yourself from it really starts becoming
mind-blowing but for me the people who
really I think bear a lion's share of
the blame for this are actually the
universities and that might sound kind
of strange but for years they've
basically had feminist studies and
african-american studies and what the
what do they have to do with their time
and there are hundreds of departments
certainly with I don't know about the
the african-american stuff but the
Women's Studies thing there are hundreds
of departments in America doing this
sort of thing and then pumping out these
special snowflakes of the astonishing
rate and either this is why I look at
some of this stuff online and you know
like the virginity is a social construct
they didn't make that up they learned
that and um yeah so in absence I think
the universities really do have to take
their Shore blame for this and now it's
an irony that the university lecturers
tend to actually say be kind of soft and
the one thing that scares the hell out
of them is being called a racist or
sexist yeah alright and this is where I
think you really saw them score their
first real victory well it wasn't a
victory victory at Mizzou where they
actually got the sculpt of the
university president yep
and it's easy you know you go up and
said well if you there's there's racism
on your campus we don't have to show any
real evidence of it but you're a racist
if you don't deal with it
it's basically emotional blackmail yeah
and isn't it a compounding problem
because once you start that root and you
sort of let the inmates run the asylum
let the students run the asylum but
ultimately the people that you're going
to get to be professors and
administrators and presidents of these
universities are not going to be as
qualified as they would have been ten
years ago because who would ever want to
be involved in that mess um absolutely
um I mean I yeah who would want to take
such a ghastly job where you saw the one
in Yale yeah backwards of course
Halloween costumes and you got this how
they talk about privilege but you know
if if you were getting an education at
Yale you've waived the right to call
anyone else privileged it's that simple
and there she is bawling your head off
as poor professor sort of saying it's
not about creating an academic
environment is about creating a home
it's like actually honey it's exactly
the opposite of that it's about creating
an intact environment and if you just
want somewhere where you can feel at
home you know go to daddy's ranch or
something you're right
and yes she said that which is the
complete reverse of what the truth is
but I don't know if you know this but
that girl that was yelling at the
professor at one point she yelled at him
she said who hired you she was on the
board of students that hired him
ya know you couldn't make this stuff up
you really couldn't and it is so hard to
tell if someone is just pretending to be
that stupid because you just can't
believe this money's actually that's
taken
and time and time again yeah you know
you said click several of their videos
just check that they're not faking it
right I know they really do believe in
this stuff they really do believe in it
how much do you think this is just
internet culture that we wake up every
morning and the second you scroll your
Twitter feed or you look at your YouTube
subscriptions you're ready to see
something that offends you and go crazy
now I know that that's not the way you
behave but that we've so trained
everyone to have an opinion about
everything that this is of course this
is the end result of that well I mean
there is you know in the Internet is a
bloodbath of free speech and is an
attention economy so if you like things
think things where the social justice
for is I think the most stupid things
are obviously gonna be the ones to get
the most attention because there is no
stupid you know how can you be a
functioning adult and still believe that
crap um so yeah I mean for me there is
so much of it out there and no i don't
be looking for it anymore but you're
right i mean it quite often if you see
it like some pop up several times the
twitter feed is it's usually with click
and you know i don't have to time to
make that many videos but oh my word
don't eat a gold might help there's a
goldmine of stupidity and like i said
these people are frequently people who
have done degrees in these subjects or
courses or something you know they just
sort of sit down well I get it no one
could come out with something that
stupid
on man you eat obviously they'd learn
this stuff is it doubly maddening to you
because you're a scientist I mean you
need empirical evidence to to make a
point right you you hypothesize
something and then you need to try to
prove it and what these people are doing
is they're put
the hypothesis is more important than
the proof so they just have this idea of
what's right and then if it doesn't
matter if they can prove it they feel
it's right that's more important than
fact I feel ease before release that
Brigade but yeah so this dis biddies
teeth grinding that they start with the
conclusion and then they look for the
facts to support their conclusion which
is the opposite way around it goes with
Sciences you look at the evidence of
World War two conclusions they start
with the conclusions you know black
people are oppressed and then they look
for the evidence for it
and it's also for them it must be a
fairly for certain fraction of the black
community it must be a very seductive
narrative that the reason that your life
sucks is because you're oppressed you
know it room there is always a balance
between having a safety net and yo
certain forcing people to stand on their
own feet making you move so this is if
you like the American Dream is people
have almost no safety net they have to
stand on their own feet and if they're
being told that it's not their fault
they're a failure it's society's fault
so there's a great Simpsons quite about
that you know Homer you're a fat bull
waste of skin and his replies which is
society's fault because almost
everything I know I learned from seasons
five to nine of The Simpsons I think
this there's there's a lot of stuff
there's a lot of good stuff in there
yeah but you can see how if you are in
it's not your fault you're like
it's that society's oppressing you and
yeah for people with feminist degrees
you can see why that might resonate with
them all right so with all this social
justice stuff in mind I've noticed that
you've referenced a lot of what's going
on in America
right now do you think this stuff is
taking root everywhere right now is it
equal or are you guys watching us right
now going you guys are the last ones
that have a chance to fight this
freaking thing because we've lost it
already that's what I suspect a little
bit from some of my European viewers
yeah so there are two imports that I
fear one comes from the Middle East of
wine comes from America ironically is
not gun culture but and yeah it's the
way I see it is that America is putting
out so many there are so many women
Studies courses the date there is this
almost critical mass of this stuff out
there and it's not really based on like
your standards based on people's
feelings and yeah that's essentially
being it is certainly imported into
England and other countries in Europe
and one of the guys I work with you know
he would watch some of my videos when so
Riley scoff yeah yeah America is always
a little funny like that it never
happened here and what do you know I
think it was like two weeks later they
had an arts exhibition which is a bit of
an arts fan and the arts exhibition was
shut down by feminists it's like yeah so
like that I see it as it's creepin doom
and we had things like Tim hunt
yeah the Nobel laureate it basically got
burned at a stake because a feminist
made an accusation out out that British
guy yeah um and you know Dawkins also
the feminist you know periodically ever
got him for being a Mossad it's one of
those things that um if you go up to a
typical academic and just so point of
the man's character misogynist all of
them will concede to almost anything
interesting yeah I think this is why
gets so much traction so quickly is
they're just not used to that level of
being attacked
especially if it's over something do
they don't is is important not the
sudden they're all these people
threatening to expose them online yeah I
can see how that raffles a lot of the
either people who live a very
antagonistic life yeah so is part of the
problem here that when you take you know
two people for example or we could take
any of those four horsemen but I but I
think Dawkins and sam Harris would be
the best examples people who have taken
other public positions out you know
outside of atheism talk to more about
politics for example that I think that
they stake out positions and then I
don't know that you know I've had Sam on
the show several times I don't know that
he's ever said to me I think I'm right
about everything he says this is what I
think about this and I think he has a
pretty malleable mind but that that the
flaw of what they've done is that they
put out a position that's well thought
out and then they expect that it's going
to be treated as such where the papal
that are going to attack them they're
just waiting for that one sentence out
of context and then it's go to town all
gloves are off
so I mean you're cool earlier are saying
that you know a lot of scientists are
terribly naive about how the real world
functions array you know there are
venues when you're expected to wear a
suit and tie or you're not taken
seriously Sam Harris I've seen several
times and either if there is a certain
level of naivety that you know because
they live in a world where people they
do try to understand what you're saying
take it seriously point out of they're
not used to this sort of bloodbath where
people are out to get you it doesn't
really matter whether it's true or not
and and yeah I was there's a certain
naivety I find to sounds expectation
that the rest of the world is going to
be like the discussions he gets at
university and you know of course you
know these people are pimping Islam and
the sites like they're going to
their different agenda to push yeah
hello good
they definitely constraints on being
fair yeah so what do you make of those
people so now not I'm not talking about
the average social justice warrior or
whatever who thinks that they are doing
something good the average college kid
who even if we ultimately disagree with
their methods but they think they're
doing something good I think it's pretty
obvious that in the public space there
are plenty of people who we know are
acting maliciously who don't mind lying
and smearing and even when evidence is
brought to bear they ignore it or deny
it and all of that stuff how does that
how do you wrap yourself around that as
a public person in this in this space so
yeah I've taken my share of slings and
arrows in the bloodbath out there and I
know whether you know this one I had ofa
a semi-regular parents town people write
to my my employer yes what if I write
this one particular stress stood out
because you know she was accusing me of
supporting Hitler and supporting the
genocide and how I was anti-feminist
which was nasty ideology anti Islam
which was Nazi ideology and it was just
it was that crazy but that was sent to
my employer um yeah and I lost my train
of thought at that point yeah well I
think they're dealing with people with
bad intentions there's sort of no end
there right right yeah but I mean this
is the thing um the way I see it is as
long as it's kept on the open market on
the playing field of free speech with
some exceptions where you get into the
cloud reliables stuff if people are
going to say things that are false about
you if it's egregiously false you can
make a devil sermon about what they've
done far better then you can make a good
case for that on the open marketplace of
ideas
and people start writing to your
employer in the sites like that this is
taking it to a different level you know
yeah so I mean that's what for me I
don't care as long as it's a ghostly
nasty stuff about me definitely I don't
really care about if they're going to
say things to the Falls if I really care
about them I can read about them you
know as long as if you're the girl out
there into the bloodbath you gotta be
able to take a punch on the chair
basically yeah so basically you got to
pick your spots otherwise your whole
channel and your whole life would be
dedicated to just playing defense yeah
absolutely and this is where it all
comes down to I can only make so many
videos I've got to choose my targets and
you're right I mean a lot of the time if
I you're right if I if I made videos
defending myself against all comers
not only does then that become the sport
right any idiot can just come along and
right do that sort of thing you got to
reply to it it takes time away from the
things that I'm actually trying to
really achieve you know counter
counteracting some other
pseudoscience out there yeah all right
so let's let's ship topics all together
and talk a little bit about Briggs it
because I did not do a ton of about it
on the show we did a little bit and the
reason for that was I said look I'm not
an expert in this I don't have a problem
admitting when I'm not an expert in
something somehow apparently that's
really innovative I didn't realize that
it wasn't but I said buy from everything
that I read my feelings were that if if
I live there that I probably would have
been for it because I believe that you
should have as much local control in
your life as possible and I wouldn't
want my decisions about my life being
exported to people in Brussels or
hundreds or thousands of miles away that
was sort of my short take on it but
you've talked a lot about it so I
thought maybe you could enlighten us a
little bit so brexit is one of those
things where there are certainly
arguments for it you know all these
things about Brussels being
crack inefficient also thing they're all
true
they're also arguments against virtually
any form of government more Stingley
some of the things that they do are
really annoying this stupid so now all
the kids toys you have to have screws to
holding the batteries so that's like
something that they said all of Europe's
gonna have to do this because one we
choked on a battery and so I don't even
think anyone choked on a battery right
because if I mean the obviously con
you're abused to have I know 20
countries each of which had different
training laws and the whole thing as you
can imagine is gargantuan ly ineffective
to trade between all these countries so
if you're actually gonna have one set of
walls for everyone there is no they
using economy there mmm-hmm right that
now anyone can trade with anyone else
fairly transparently and so as long as
you don't get 20 times more ineffective
with that one set of rules it'll be on
the big picture a win right right
because you're not wasting as much time
with the bureaucracy trading the problem
is that of course you kept all these
people say what rules are we gonna have
and all these people all they basically
do is make it rules right and so they
make up some pretty stupid rules
but essentially essentially that's the
majority of what the Europe is now I
mean the majority we used to be
something called the Common Agricultural
Policy which was born out of the best of
intentions and was rivaled only by how
the scale of its failure in that I think
it got something like sixty percent of
the European budget was going on this
Common Agricultural Policy so he's born
out of the end of World War two they
decided that you know if you're just
going to do anything it's going to
secure the food supply you don't really
want the food supply to be completely at
the wins of free trade in the you know
when your farmers going out of pace
in the bad gears or you know because
then in the good years you might not
have enough farmers to make enough food
that was the general idea and there was
there is some sense to that that you
want the stability in the food supply
problem is of course that farming
techniques got a lot more effective
molasses a thing in the idea of running
out of food became they had it at the
end of World War two which was like that
was an issue so that evaporated very
quickly and now you've got all of these
subsidized farmers and they were just
producing loads of food and there was
nothing they could do with it so they
had all these breaking yeah wheat
Mountains and bottom lakes and wine
whatever the white line sounds kind of
good yeah yeah the white light um but
then comes the question well it's
shameful just have it we'll we'll just
dump it on the market which of course
now under cuss farmers ever else in the
world so it was a gargantuan waste of
money and all that sort of thing but
that they've cut that way back now and
so what you're mostly is this trade
agreement um and there is also there's
the European Court of Human Rights and
some other bits tied onto it they are
mostly toothless like the United Nations
in that no one really wanted to give up
any sovereignty to these bodies so they
they basically they don't really have
much in the way of power there's no real
enforcement mechanism for any of this
then they are the whatever the Euro
which was also Union of the currency
before you have you humor the fiscal
policy you don't have to be Einstein to
work out that that's probably you're not
going to end very well and that's an
ongoing problem so I mean that there are
myriad criticisms of Europe but for
England the thing is the if at the
moment anyone in the world wants to
trade with England it's easy they just
use the same rules as he did with anyone
else
right now you're going to basically have
to rewrite all those and everybody
trades with England's can have to work
out what the hell they are yeah um so um
and in practice it's probably not going
to change that much right yeah what what
what what are the costs what are the
benefits it's probably on the big
picture not going to change a lot in
England one way or the other but the
change from one system to the other as a
gargantuan pain in the ass for any
trades with England and for what I mean
it's a distinction without a difference
right so you're going all from the
economic side so far from from what I
gathered what I sense that a huge amount
of it had to do with the immigration
situation which I don't you think maybe
you were a little more sympathetic to
the rags of Tears on that right uh well
yes and no so for the bride she is
absolutely not because England right
there's two basic regions in Europe this
changing a non-schengen you case
non-schengen so if you actually come
from Europe to England you have to show
your passport so if you're a legitimate
citizen of Europe you get free feet free
movement over Europe England still have
its own border border controls so for
that there would be no change if you're
talking about the influx of refugees
from the Middle East well yeah that this
is a very big problem and countries like
Germany have really kind of screwed the
pooch on that again the argument is
primary economical in that if used too
soon the ramming that then will be cut
there are cultural problems as we've
seen but the economic argument is
Germany's country of about ninety
million people or something they're
getting 1/2 million extra people in
their young ones generally had a problem
because young people adopt adapt to the
culture the people a little older
they're not going to be able to learn
the language they're not going to blend
into the culture and they're probably
not really much the we're marketable
skills they basically
into two percent burden on your country
for the next generation and if you just
do those go back around for like
calculations it's crippling you know
you're talking you know trillions of
dollars that sort of thing but again you
know one of the real problems was that
there was no real no-one's really given
any power to Europe so it's got no
enforcement mechanisms you know what
would what can you do with all these
refugees yeah well this was their real
debate about it because I think that's
one of the problems we're having here is
we're not debating the real things
because you either are for immigration
where you're a racist so we don't have a
real debate so I would imagine in in
Germany and for all the economic reasons
you're talking about you could make a
strong argument against immigration on
purely economic grounds and I'm sure you
can make an argument for immigration on
immigrant economic grounds too but was
that conversation even being had or was
it just let them in or you're racist in
Germany um they've got a no they for the
large part was if you didn't let the the
immigrants in you don't think of them
now should we say a tainted history with
this sort of thing right so that
probably there's probably a lot of
overcompensation going on there but that
was basically the overwhelming attitude
in Germany recently they've all these
attacks from trains with just people
stabbing people an thing again
you know if you're looking in terms of
macroscopic costs this is nothing
compared to the costs of transport two
million people for a generation but
that's the sort of thing that the the
knife attacks I think of the things that
are starting to change opinions in
Europe ironically now that's actually
manifesting itself as a problem people
are starting to take it more seriously
yeah all right so I want to wrap up with
you on just free speech in a broad sense
because I think from all the people I
have the YouTube people that I've talked
to this week and pretty
from almost every guest that I've had on
almost everything these days for the
online world is couched in free speech
and in just a couple weeks it sounds
like the UN might take control of the
Internet have you been paying attention
to this thing at all
I missed that I've been kind of out of
town for the past couple of weeks
correct your vision sounds like now the
United States is giving up control of
the Internet I haven't even paid as much
attention as I should to it maybe I'll
do something on it before it's too late
but that there's just so much related to
free speech that everything that the
mainstream media has just failed us in
in all of our countries and that we're
fighting for free speech and free
thought online and even that now is
becoming a precarious thing you know
Milo getting booted from Twitter we know
about Facebook banning all kinds of X
Muslims and and other people that are
genuinely the good guys were you banned
will you ban from baseball I've been
banned from both you were banned for by
if I've done the trend for typing bound
from YouTube as well we're getting the
trifecta yeah that's I've been bad on
everything weights again we break down
each one what was the Twitter one I
think was first right uh the know now
that YouTube was first that was a long
time ago fact that's why my bunny is
glowing my little bunny icon is because
after three days I came back from from
the band you come what were you man for
on YouTube I can't remember I think he
was DMCA stuff you know people basically
using the DMC as a weapon which they're
done on and off for you know the last
ten years and I think that's what took
it down it might have been the flacking
I can't actually remember it's a long
time ago now but I was banned from
YouTube came back Facebook it I think
that was to do with Islam and the
Twitter was certainly to do with
feminism so you've covered that's it
that's a good range to be banned from
three different things for three
different reasons that's pretty good
yeah and you're still standing yeah has
it worked
yeah I am I'm surprised in many ways
that I've lost it
long cuz this is my fear knowing exactly
what you were saying is um YouTube is
almost the last bastion the allows a
robust exchange over a robust defense of
what we would recognize as free speech
so basically you're allowed to say
whatever you want as long as it's you
know not involving you did not bullying
kids or something you know kids are any
different category so they Ted juniors
not threatening violence you know into
keeping down on the splattered damage
you know saying bad things about you is
fine don't say bad things about your dad
or something like that right you know
there are so as long as that you're sort
of a bang some pretty liberal rules as
far as I'm concerned free game is is
where it should be
YouTube's been very good with that I
suspect it's mostly because that's the
successful business model and that the
bigger the fruit the bigger the market
the bigger the bloodbath is the more
views in an intentional economy that
means that YouTube pulls in the most
money so that that really is the best
argument you could possibly make for
free markets right yes but it's also
worrying in that the because you must
realize this as well that all it takes
is a few keystrokes from someone at
YouTube and we're all done yeah you know
all the work that we put into this all
the videos that we've made fun just gone
yeah they can be vanished like that that
I find worrying the restoring thing is
YouTube doesn't seem to begin in that
rude Twitter certainly does and and
Facebook does as well and another
financial reason for the hands-off
approach to free speech is once you've
with the more complicated the set of
rules you have the more people you need
to enforce them and once it becomes
clear that if you don't like someone you
flag them enough and you can get rid of
them then you basically you you open the
gate
it's the floodgates to the flagging ball
yeah and I argue they've had those
several times on YouTube and yeah I
think they sort of bagged it they've got
really pretty robust very liberal
boundaries on what they call free speech
on YouTube which i think is fantastic
but you don't get that on Twitter you
don't get that on Facebook um yeah and
it seems to be much more at the whim of
the ideology of the owner then yeah
Google doesn't really have an ideology
maggot but that maybe goes back to the
origin of Google which is we don't
create media we just tell people how to
locate it and then we put adverts on it
right so they didn't care what the
actual content was they were selling the
metadata telling you how to find stuff
and you know maybe that's also what
they're sort of pursuing with YouTube is
they're not the policemen of the content
yeah within certain really very broad
limits right sort of like true vile
calls to violence or something of that
nature I guess that's the way that we
would want it to be which is they give
us a service they take a chunk of the ad
revenue we most people know that we're
not we're not rolling in dough because
of YouTube ads but they're giving us the
service and allowing people to find us
but I think you do make an interesting
point about the way people are being
censored which a lot of times again it
is the inmates running the asylum
because I've talked to people at
Facebook where they say it's not our
algorithm and it's not us that are doing
it it's all there's there's a mob of
people clicking whatever it is down vote
or censor or offended or whatever the
button is I don't know what the button
is anymore but if there's an army of
people doing it and then that triggers
the system and then usually these people
come back but that's kind of scary too
whether it's coming directly from
Facebook or it's just the mob because
the mob is always probably going to be
bigger than the freethinkers mm yeah but
this is where things like um you know
for Charla such like they could be
equalizes all this if if it becomes
clear that people can just simply
abusive mechanisms like this a lot of
these people who are out in the streets
are saying we need these tools to keep
us safe they will be number two on the
chopping block right thing if it becomes
that easy to get people waxed yep they
will be gone within a week of the people
that want to get rid of yeah because I
mean or was it and yeah because the
Internet's got a sense of karma like
that I guess that's the saving grace
here I suppose
well fili really it's been a pleasure
talking to you I'm glad we did this
after probably should have done it about
two years ago but better late than ever
so I want to thank Phil Mason aka
Thunderfoot for joining me on the Rubin
report for YouTube week and you guys can
check out his channel at youtube.com
slash Thunderfoot those last two rows
are zeros and there is a link right down
below thanks again Phil
[Music]
you